Here are the centers and here are the radii. Great work, if you figured each of
them out. Let's start by focusing on the center. Remember the center is at h, k
and we take the sign that's opposite and this parenthesis. So, we know the x
coordinate here is positive 1 and the y coordinate of the center is positive 2.
This is the h value. This is the k value. For this second one we'll have
negative three for the x coordinate of our center. This is our h value. And
we'll have positive 3 for the y coordinate of our center. This is the k value.
And notice that since these signs match, we just take the positive 3 for k
whereas here we have to have negative 3 for the value of h. This third one
might have been tricky. We'll have positive 7 for the x coordinate of our
center and we'll have 0 for the y coordinate of our center. There's nothing or
subtracted in parentheses for this y, so we know the k value is just 0. And
finally for the last one we'll have negative 4, 2 for this center. We change
the sign here and we change the sign here. Now let's focus on the radius. If we
take the square root of the number on the end, we get the radius. So, the
square root of 16 equals 4, the square root of 1 equals 1, and the square root
of 49 equals 7. For this last one, we'll take the square root of 8, which
really equals 2 root 2. Now, you could have just written square root of 8 and
that would have been correct as well. These two are the same number.